if your esc runs blheli s then i don't
blame you if you've been feeling a
little bit like a second class citizen
lately it seems like all the cool new
features go into blheli32 and blheli s
is just left out
and i i mean features that improve the
flight performance of your quadcopter
like a bi-directional d-shot so you can
do rpm filtering yeah blhelios didn't
support that for a long time
or features like uh like this
[Music]
huh yeah the ability to play music or
sounds when you first plug in okay it's
not going to make your quad fly better
but it sure is cool to be able to
personalize it in that way
today i'm going to show you a firmware
for blheli s that lets you get in on
many of these features and if you've
seen previous videos i've done about
jesc and jazz maverick no this is not
them i've got another recommendation
today and i'm going to tell you why
today bluej is the firmware that you
want to be running on your blheli scsc
and there is a newer even easier way to
flash bluej and a couple other firmwares
i'm joshua bardwell you're going to
learn something today
[Music]
before i tell you why blue jay is the
firmware that i recommend you put on
your bill hilly s esc's today i just
want to acknowledge the work done
previously by joe lucid uh for with the
jesc firmware and jazz maverick on the
jazz maverick firmware um all of these
people have contributed to the open
source uh expansion of the blheli s code
and many of these firmwares wouldn't be
here without the work they've done
there's nothing wrong with these
firmwares per se
but jdsc firmware uh it costs money
that's fine joe lucid wanted to charge
money for his work i don't begrudge him
that but there's a firmware that
basically does the same thing for free
so most people will probably choose that
especially because when you buy a jesc
license if your esc dies you don't get
that money back
and a lot of people are annoyed by that
that's actually always how it's worked
you just pay the license when you first
buy the esc they don't give you a back
when it dies but a lot of people are a
little bit annoyed about that so
and as far as jazz maverick goes well
the last update was august 2020 it's a
little bit out of date so the firmware
we're looking at here is called bluej
and yes you can flash it with a
standalone app if you prefer to download
the app to your hard drive but even
cooler there is a browser-based flasher
and a lot of people are going to like
that and find it more convenient than
downloading an app to their hard drive
the url is esc-configurator.com
and there's a link to that down in the
video description as you would expect so
in order to use this
we're just going to plug usb into the
flight controller and plug in a battery
to power up the esc
and then here in the browser i'm going
to hit open port selection and i'm going
to choose the com port of the flight
controller the very first time you do
this chrome is going to ask you for
permissions to access the com ports and
then once you do that you don't have to
do that again
by the way this is you'll need a chrome
based browser which
basically all of them are today but
yeah
so then we'll hit connect and we will
hit connect and now we are connected to
the esc and the next thing i'll do is
hit read setup down here in the lower
right now if you've used blheli s
configurator before then this all looks
very familiar and in fact i wouldn't be
surprised to learn it's all based on the
same code because it's all open source
many of the things in here are going to
be familiar to you
you can set whether the motor is
reversed you can change the ppm min and
max throttle if you're using d-shot you
don't have to worry about that
and over here on the left we've got
options like startup power temperature
protection the standard esc based
options that you're used to seeing
but if we flash the blue jay firmware
we're going to see some extra stuff so
let's go ahead and do that down here in
the lower right i'm going to hit flash
all
and the firmware i'm going to flash is
going to be bluej
for esc just leave this at whatever it
is gh30 don't change that because you'll
mess up your esc
and for version i suppose i'm going to
pick the latest version i don't know
what erpm test is but i don't think i
want test firmware
and then we got the first option that we
can select that's new with this firmware
the pwm frequency now on
blh32escs you don't have to flash
different firmware to change the motor
pwm frequency you can just change it in
software but on these blhelis esc's they
don't have enough space for the code how
do you choose which pwm frequency you
want for very small quads like
toothpicks and smaller down to 65
millimeter tiny whoops generally the
higher the pwm frequency the longer the
flight time you're going to get and this
is
much much more true for like 65
millimeter tiny whoops than it is for
like three inch toothpicks in fact maybe
even at the three inch size it doesn't
make sense anymore um this is a this is
a three inch
it's not really a toothpick though
so maybe i'm going to pick the middle 48
kilohertz the higher the frequency the
smoother the motors are going to be in
general so some people would argue that
for larger like freestyle quads you
would want the 96 kilohertz pwm
frequency the problem with that is that
the higher pwm frequencies also
significantly reduce braking torque and
they can make the quad handle worse so
for larger freestyle quads like five
inches and up you probably are going to
want to pick 24
for tiny whoops and so forth you're
definitely going to pick 96 and
somewhere around 3 inches maybe you'd
pick 48
yeah that's what you're going to go for
so then i'm just going to hit flash and
it's going to go flash all of those
esc's after you're done flashing you're
going to see that there's some new
options here that are unique to the
bluej firmware and we're going to go
through a couple of those what they mean
and how to tune them but the number one
thing you've got is not an option it's
just there and that is access to
bi-directional d-shot so here in
betaflight we can go to the well i'm in
the motors tab in betaflight
configurator 10.8 which is the newest
version uh that has just come out
they've moved the dshot settings to the
motors tab they used to be in the
configuration tab if you're on
10 7 they're going to be in the
configuration tab
we can enable bi-directional d-shot and
save and reboot
and then here in the motors tab we can
see zero percent errors which with bless
we would now see a hundred percent
errors because it doesn't support
bi-directional d-shot we can now uh use
rpm filtering here in the pin tuning tab
we can go to the filter settings and you
can see that the gyro rpm filter is
enabled and that's fantastic that is
everybody should do that everybody
should do that and in fact once you've
done that you should also go ahead and
turn off the gyro lope whichever one low
pass leave gyro low pass two and leave
the d term that once you enable the gyro
rpm filter it's almost always safe to
just go ahead and disable that and uh
you know get some get your quadcopter
flying just a little bit better this
isn't a tuning guide this is about the
esc let's continue another feature that
you're really going to enjoy is the
ability to customize the startup sound
to make that be a song or sound
something that you personalize for
yourself why would you want to hear the
standard startup music every time you
plug in how boring
you're going to access that through the
melody editor here
and you can make your own melodies the
format is ringtone text transfer
language or rttl
and there's documentation online about
how to create rttl files but
is actually also just a library of
pre-made ones that you can pick
for example how about the rick and morty
theme we can even play it to uh
yeah there you go we can even play it to
hear what it sounds like and when we're
ready to go
we will
accept
each one
i believe so yes accept it and then
write melodies
shut up
you know that's the coolest thing you've
ever freaking heard
yeah finally my micro quads can have the
same startup tone as my big quad
like i always wanted
nice
that's that's what we need from life now
let's get to the serious stuff uh these
options over here and
the default options work fine that's why
they're the defaults if this stuff kind
of breaks your brain a little bit that
just fly the defaults and have fun and
enjoy your your new startup tones and
your bi-directional d-shot rpm filtering
now here in the bluej firmware we've got
two parameters that relate to startup
power one is the minimum and one is the
maximum and the way it works is that the
esc will start sort of kicking the motor
with the minimum startup power and if
the motor doesn't begin to spin smoothly
and back emf is detected then it will
slowly increase how hard it kicks the
motor until it reaches the maximum and
at that point hopefully the motor will
be spinning and the problem is that if
that electrical pulse that initial blind
kick is too weak the motor won't begin
to spin
it's not great but it's not the worst
thing in the world
if that pulse is too strong the motor
can be damaged for example what if the
motor isn't spinning because it's
blocked by a branch and you're like ah
start spinning you son of a ah you just
burned a motor so what the esc is gonna
do is it's gonna start with the minimum
startup power
and if the motor doesn't begin to spin
it's going to ramp up to the maximum
startup power
so the maximum startup power needs to be
low enough or that it doesn't let the
motor fry
and i don't know how you tune that value
just raise it until you fry a motor
i really don't so we're just going to
leave that at the default
the minimum startup power we can
actually tune to try and make it be just
high enough to get the motor going while
well not sort of over
kicking the motor if you will moving on
down the parameters we've got motor
timing
and the short value short version is
that you can set this timing from medium
high to high which decreases the odds of
a desync but can also make the motors
run hotter and less efficient it can
also make a little bit more power
sometimes a lot of racers prefer to run
at high timing the highest possible
timing there isn't really a compelling
reason to turn the timing down
that i can think of
like really big low kv motors you might
want to turn the timing down i suppose
because they're spinning so slowly now
but the default timing is probably fine
if you want a little bit more power at
the expense of efficiency turn it up to
high
dmag compensation uh that is a safety
setting where if the esc thinks that the
motor has desynced it will go into a
mode where it does what's called blind
commutation where it just tries to
commute the motor commutate the motor
without detecting zero crossings and low
is a fine value for most people if you
have a particularly desync prone
quadcopter you can set it to high and it
may fix your dsyncs
and basically nobody should set it to
off
probably beep strength is how loud the
motors beep if you turn this up you do
risk heating your motors up if the left
beeping too long but they will be louder
beacon strength is when the esc is
powered down for too long and it begins
to beep because it thinks you've lost it
that's how strong that will be uh and
oh we missed rpm power protection that
is how hard the esc will try to
accelerate the motor when it's already
spinning so if you're in a situation
where the motor is spinning and then
suddenly it needs to accelerate by
turning this up
it will accelerate harder but there will
be a greater chance of a desync or a
fried motor so you definitely could try
turning this up if you want more
responsive motors but you have much
higher risk of frying something and then
the last setting we're going to talk
about is dithering which should
basically always be on
unless you're using 24k pwm frequency
because without it your motor resolution
will be extremely low and that's going
to bring us to the end of the video
i am putting bluej on all of my quads
with bl heli s esc's to gain access to
bi-directional d-shot rpm filtering and
yes the mario power-up sound which is
more important to me than you know
if you're interested in tweaking some of
those advanced options that's cool but
even if you're not i suggest you flash
this and that is the advice that i not
just me but i talked to a whole bunch of
other people i know who a lot of people
who fly micro quads with bl heli scscs
and this is the firmware they're all
using too sorry jesc jazz maverick etc
this just seems to be where people are
at
so there's links in the video
description to all the stuff if you're
interested and uh yeah oh right
if you value content like this i have a
patreon page patreon is a website where
you can subscribe to me for as little as
two dollars a month or more if you feel
like i've earned it you're totally in
charge of how much you decide to spend
it helps support me every month helps me
pay the bills
and helps me keep making content like
this but don't worry content like this
will always be available for free so if
today is not the day where you feel like
i've earned it that's fine keep watching
and hopefully that day will come but if
that today is that day down in the video
description is a link to patreon.com as
well as some other ways you can support
me thanks for watching happy flying
what are you doing in here
the least you could do is subscribe or
join my patreon or
like just here's another video i picked
out for you
jeez